what do you think the average somebody
spends this if the average person walks
in the door do we know what that number
is are you allowed to say no we see it's
telling that you know there is an
average number it's definitely not a uh
immediate no no the average is a couple
hundred dollars probably per person but
it's skewed uh where
certainly the there's there's some
people have spent six figures over there
they've never dropped a million bucks
every single year
yeah
for the bitcoin available
showed up to 11 the single most
profitable nightclub per square foot in
the world
spent almost a million dollars to
convert whether it was cash or
bitcoin use bitcoin they converted
almost a million dollars of bitcoin into
singles and then turned around and spent
for two hours literally throwing singles
yeah at the club yeah up in the air yep
we love that guy yeah
he could have bought a condo across the
street i think he bought a condo across
the street too so i think i know who
this person is actually
when you see something like that like
how do you keep that person coming back
like obviously a million dollars is like
a insane amount of money for most people
to think about going to the club and
doing something like that is it just
because like that's a penny to that
individual right and uh you're like oh
they'll be back because literally it
didn't matter to them or are there
things that you could do to kind of
cultivate the relationships with those
types of clientele
that come in yeah i think the experience
is different every night certainly with
the main performer whether it's a tiesto
it's one vibe or if it's a cardi b it's
a completely different
the people that are there so they're
getting a different experience every
night at 11 evolves a little bit there's
consistencies but there's evolution
but then there's other products and and
lifestyle
that we could provide these people to
and and generally um you know mark ends
up taking him out to dinner uh once or
twice a week so he's cultivating him
that way do you go out to dinner every
night i don't know how he does it i go
out to dinner a lot but it's with my
wife and kids most nights
i i don't know how mark does it but you
are a machine my friend
hey listen you know
you can't build a network sitting home
that that that is probably one of the
most truthful things i've ever heard it
is uh it's very true